[Musique]
ça fait maintenant trois ans mais j'ai
démissionné du jour au lendemain d'une
carrière bien tracée dans une grosse
corporation ça faisait longtemps que je
pensais
mais si à lundi matin que ça s'est passé
en pleine rencontre de projets j'ai fait
semblant de répondre à mon cellulaire
pige sorti j'ai jamais remis les pieds
au bureau
la raison l'objectif derrière ça trouver
des réponses à mes questions est-ce que
l'énergie que je mets au travail à
chaque jour fait vraiment une différence
parce qu'en tant qu'ingénieur mon
quotidien consiste à sauver des vies
à quoi ça qu'est ce que je fais ici si
je disparais ce que la planète même vers
une différence mon médecin de famille
m'a diagnostiqué un épuisement
professionnel mois avait du temps
carrière enviable dissociables
stimulante
je vous cacherais pas que j'ai vécu
quelques mois d'ici suite à ma démission
j'ai quitté mon appartement dans
l'atelier à montréal pour aller habiter
chez mon oncle je travaillait comme
serveuse de trois semaines mais j'avais
un objectif bien précis donner un sens à
main après quelques mois la conclusion
était clair en fait j'étais pas la
recherche d'un emploi qui allait
m'apporter un sentiment
d'accomplissement
j'étais plutôt à la recherche de mon peu
plus c'est avec ce peuple qui te l'a
trouvé un sentiment d'accomplissement au
travers de ma carrière
alors le peuple c'est quoi c'est un mot
qui se traduit pas super bien l'anglais
mais derrière le mot peur puce ces
caches les mots intentions accomplir un
but donc par rapport à ma carrière
mission quelle est ma mission
après quelques mois la conclusion était
clair plein d'autres gens autour de moi
avec ce même problème
cette quête de sens surtout ma
génération c'est ce qui m'a amené à
découvrir le terme des milléniaux alors
les milenio c'est qui c'est quoi c'est
une génération qui ont aujourd'hui entre
20 et 35 ans personnellement moi je vous
dirais que c'est une génération qui
tente délibérément d'utiliser leur
potentiel to make this world
béatrice mais je sais que certains
d'entre vous dirais plutôt les milenio
ils comprennent pas qu'il faut
travailler fort pour avoir ce qu'on veut
dans la vie sont toujours en train de
remettre les façons de faire en question
ils en veulent plus et toujours plus
toujours le coup pencher sur leur
cellulaire
en plus il parle de faire une différence
puis avoir un impact alors qu'ils sont
prêts à rester en poste pendant plus de
deux ans pile pire c'est qu'ils parlent
de prendre une sabbatique à l'âge de 25
ans pour voyager wright
bref peu importe la définition
j'ai compris qui est plein aux gens ont
cette quête de sens je me suis donc
penché sur le sujet aller voir ce qui se
cache derrière ce comprendre la tendance
parce qu'enfin qui tenait ce
scientifique
je sais bien que derrière toutes
tendances se cache une corrélation
résultats des recherches s'est donnée
résultats des sondages ça explique kelly
milenio font chuter le taux de rétention
dans les organisations s'explique pour
qu'on démissionne
ça dit aussi à quel point on peut être
désagréable
bref plein de pignons la stratégie en ce
moment on analyse les résultats des
sondages et les statistiques liées à la
rétention puis on essaie d'adapter les
stratégies à l'inter dans les
organisations en vue de répondre aux
désirs des millions gros focus sur le
leadership
on donne la fixité travailler le monde
aux employés ont neuf des package
hallucinant de style vacances est limité
bref c'est cool tout ça
mais est ce qu'il s'arrête vraiment le
problème ou s'agit plutôt comme un
bandage sur une plaie en ce moment c'est
comme si les millenium sont un gros mal
de tête mais comprend des adieux à
chaque jour tout comprendre ce qui cause
dans la tête parce que le fait de
vouloir plus de vacances et de coaching
plutôt qu'un fonds de pension est ce qui
explique pourquoi pourquoi on est comme
ça c'est que ce que j'allais chercher le
pourquoi je peux aussi vous décrire à
quoi ressemblait le plafond de ma chance
chez mon oncle donc en résolution de
problèmes
on fait quoi on pose des données
existantes on dresse le portrait de la
situation actuelle donc je me suis
demandé les mellino c'est quoi si une
génération une génération c'est quoi
c'est un environnement et les individus
au niveau de l'environnement
quels sont les facteurs qui changent au
fil des ans versus ceux qui changent pas
d quelle façon ces facteurs qui change
ont une influence sur lui même donc de
quelle façon ces facteurs qui sans ce
crime génération avec des besoins bien
distincts les millions qu'est-ce qui est
apparu pour nous dans notre
environnement réseaux sociaux instagram
les messages textes des 10èmes accès à
l'information instantanée tine 2
bref il ya un facteur qui englobe tout
ça et c'est la technologie
donc si on suit ton raisonnement de
quelle façon la technologie crée des
besoins bien dit elle aimait lignon 5 cm
qui m'a apporté deux thèmes qui allait
répondre à mes questions
auteur de wilders est vaste il fait le
parallèle entre le leadership dans les
organisations et quoi les hormones parce
qu'en fait on a dit une génération c'est
quoi des individus et un environnement
donc la technologie est entre autres
désormais 5 scénique dresse le parallèle
de 4 hormones en particulier celles qui
sont responsables des sentiments liés au
bonheur sont bien là bof c'est qu'en
fait on a des systèmes à l'intérieur de
nous qu'il faut faire des choses dans le
but d'être gardé en vie
c'est ce qui fait de nous un animal
social amour bonheur sentiment
d'accomplissement
c'est grâce à ces systèmes donc ces
hormones que l'homo sapiens a survécu
par mi-temps d'espèce il ya quatre
nouveaux transmetteurs et hormones en
particulier qui sont liées au bonheur
endorphines dopamine si retenu est aussi
les deux premiers sont sécrétées par
l'individu solo tandis que les deux
autres sont sécrétées par les
interactions avec les autres dopamine
son rhum il faire accomplir des choses
c'est la dopamine que pousser l'homo
sapiens aller cueillir et chasser pour
se nourrir
la dopamine nous fait sentir bien quand
on construit quelque chose qu'on a
besoin qu'on trouve quelque chose qu'on
cherche qu on atteint nos objectifs le
simple fait de payer quelque chose sur
une check list nous fait sécréter de la
dopamine
aujourd'hui il existe une multitude de
façons dans ses critiques lui ment
inventé alcool drogue mais également
tels que vous voyez venir à chaque fois
qu'on reçoit un like sur une photo un
message texte
les petites de messenger
toutes les notifications de toutes
sortes dopamine dopamine dopamine s'il
ya un point important est hyper à
retenir c'est qu'on peut créer une
dépendance à la dopamine
mais ensuite quand leur fils son rôle
masquer la douleur celle endorphines qui
a donné la patience l'endurance et
l'énergie a le mot s'appelait pour
marcher pendant des jours à la recherche
de nourriture l'endorphine c'est le
fameux feeling après l'entraînement qui
me fait réaliser à quel point on sent
bien que le ciel est beau l'endorphine
masquer la douleur de sorte à ce que
notre corps sont en mesure d'accomplir
ce qu'on est en train d'accomplir deux
prochaines hormones si le twin ocytocine
sécrétée par les interactions sociales
la sérotonine con las écrite quand on
ressent la fierté et la reconnaissance
publique
le fait de sécréter de la sérotonine
fait augmenter la confiance en soi le
meilleur aspect da sérotonine ce qui est
par exemple mes amis qui sont venus voir
ce soir c'est crêpes la sérotonine en ce
moment ils savent à quel point j'ai
travaillé fort pour monter des dons qui
sont fiers le moins piment cij larissa
échanges liens sociaux ensuite est aussi
s'il hormones si le sentiment de l'amour
sous toutes ses formes
son rôle le faire faire des belles
choses pour les autres en restant les
bienfaits des cytokines lorsque l'on
pose par exemple un acte de générosité
sans attendre quoi que ce soit en retour
aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement trop
souvent en publiant sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on va chercher chercher un
sentiment de reconnaissance publique
vise dit malheureusement parce qu'en
fait le mécanisme biologique chèque on
devrait avoir des interactions sociales
pour ressentir les bienfaits l'ocytocine
donc on ne ressent pas les effets de
l'ocytocine qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir
nos hormones du bonheur son débat lancé
deux choses 1
la technologie nous rends complètement
accro à la dopamine 2 la technologie ne
permet pas de ressentir les bienfaits de
sitôt si donc sa chance à s'y coller pas
concret pour les milliers nous d'abord
il faut se demander
l'absence de site hocine se répercute
comment aimer y aider je veux faire une
différence je veux sortir que j'ai eu
d'impact le débat lancement au niveau de
l'os sauce ils ne nous permet pas
d'assumer notre besoin d'aidé ensuite
notre fameuse dépendance à la dopamine
qu'est ce que ça vient expliquer comment
cette dépense ce constat question des
répercussions sur cette image ne vous
rapelle ne vous rappelle t il pas une
certaine théorie l'évolution et darwin
dit quoi darron dit qu'au fil des ans
les espèces animales et végétales par
sélection naturelle se sont adaptés à
leur environnement et que c'est à la fin
de cette longue évolution
quel humain à prix fort mais qui a dit
que l'évolution était fini quelques
relations peuvent venir tracé
aujourd'hui avec la dopamine puisqu'on a
dit que c'est la dopamine que poussines
homo sapiens aller cueillir et chasser
pour se nourrir et à éventuellement
construire ces outils et ainsi de suite
on pourrait donc aussi dire que l'on
sapiens a pris forme à évoluer xl a fait
cette longue évolution en s'adaptant son
environnement qui lui découle d'une
relation cause à effet entre notre
dopamine est ce qu'on a accompli
si on suit mon raisonnement comment on
peut comprendre que notre dopamine nous
pousse entreprendre aujourd'hui comment
les générations avant nous sont allés de
l'avant pour qu'on soit assis ici
aujourd'hui dans cette salle en tant
qu'humain oui mais aussi en tant que
groupe en tant que société chose
certaine est très rationnelle les
générations avant nous ont accompli des
choses le langage l'écriture
le concept de s'asseoir pour regarder un
spectacle tout ça est parti d'un humain
qui a eu l'idée oui mais aussi la
motivation pour aller au bout de son
idée
si maintenant on s'intéresse à l'humain
derrière ça et c'est par exemple à
l'époque tout le monde avait l'entregent
nécessaire pour faire des trucs la
vision pour implanter le concept de la
monnaie l'esprit de synthèse pour
découvrir les chiffres
peu importe la génération on peut dire
que des gens ont mis à l'oeuvre leur
potentiel et leur talent pour contribuer
à construire leur société et la faire
évoluer
donc pour une cause plus grande qu
humain maintenant si on vient au
millénium qui à la recherche de leur
père fils peut-être qu'au fond il
faudrait se demander est ce que je sens
que je contribue à faire évoluer ma
société est ce que j'utilise mon talent
mes forces et mon potentiel pour y
arriver
si vous posez cette question un
millennials aujourd'hui possible il ya
un petit moment d'hésitation
pourquoi c'est qu'en fait on a été
conditionnée à se définir avec notre
emploi je m'appelle zainab je suis
ingénieur plutôt qu'être comprendre
qu'ils ont nés puis trouver un emploi
qui découlent de qui on est j'aime
réinventer les façons de faire de ça
vient ça saviez ce que j'appelle la
technique du bonheur ça consiste en quoi
c'est les étapes qu'on nous présentait
au millennium de pics du jeune comme
étant la marche à suivre pour avoir une
vie réussie fois l' université obtenir
son diplôme signé un contrat pour un
emploi payant être en couple se marier
acheter un condo des ménages dans une
maison avant des enfants va poser du
tavini
notre vie en soi est une check-list
chaque étape franchie nous apporte un
rush de dopamine donc une dose de
bonheur mais le problème c'est qu'on vit
notre vie on accomplit des choses
en suivant un mode d'emploi on est une
génération qui s'est éloigné de ce que
notre besoin de dopamine cherche à
l'effort accompli la technologie et la
check list du bonheur ils ont éloigné de
notre peuple
il faut revenir à la base il faut
retourner à la façon naturelle de
sécréter nos hormones il faut chercher à
balancer nos hormones du bonheur dit en
guise de dopamine trouver des façons de
sécréter l'ocytocine puis en parallèle
découvrir l'ampleur de son potentiel
pour éventuellement la porte est une
cause plus grand que soi même juste
sérieusement comment faire tout ce
travail de développement personnel tout
en continuant à les travailler
peut-être que les organisations ont une
plus grande part de responsabilité qu'on
pense dans cette quête de sens en
s'assurant la voir en place des leaders
qui ne font sécréter la sérotonine comme
le suggère ça a mentionné mais également
envoyé en mission en entreprise pour
s'assurer que simple fait d'aller
travailler phase écrite et le site aussi
dans nos employés le mettre à la
disposition des milléniaux des
incitatifs pour leur fabriquer leurs
dépenses de revoir sa mission
d'entreprise pour s'assurer de faire
évoluer la société dans la bonne
direction
peut-être qu'alors il serait possible
pour les millénium de trouver une
réponse à leur quête de sens merci
[Applaudissements]